hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in book two of his work the art of
rhetoric aristotle is going to
look at the human emotions and the one
that he focuses on first is that of
anger in greek it's orgay and that's the
term that he consistently uses for it
although he also does sometimes use this
term thumos as well synonymously with
organe at other times thumus names
something a bit broader in scope that
includes anger but also extends to other
matters as well
and
aristotle is providing us his readers
with a very
rich complex attentive
definition you could call it of anger he
doesn't actually use the word definition
instead he says esto let anger be
so he's you know he's telling us what it
is what he thinks that it is and the
many different components
of this highlight aspects of anger that
we
ourselves might often miss out on we
might not be adequately attentive to
when we're getting angry or thinking
about our own anger or thinking about
others anger or
anger in
general so let's look at each of these
components or dimensions in turn he
begins by saying
what kind of thing it is
anger is a kind of desire orexis in
greek means desire and it means that in
a very broad sense that includes
you could say not just plain old desire
to like eat or have sex or watch tv or
something like that but affectivity
in general and in fact
aristotle tells us that one of the main
kinds of orexis desire
is thumos the
the active riled up could lead to anger
concerned with status
part of
the soul and plato in aristotle that's
not a part of the soul it's rather a
modality of desire so anger is desire
but that's not the only thing that we
feel when we're angry
he highlights two other really important
aspects it is accompanied he says by
pain
this doesn't mean physical pain
necessarily although sometimes people do
get psychosomatic uh symptoms or
expressions of their anger you know
feeling their test their chest get
tighter or something like that or you
know seeing their hands tremble because
of the adrenaline flowing through them
turning different colors
but lupus pain in this case can mean
something broader than just physical
pain it means really disturbance
things that we are bothered by anger is
a painful emotion to feel and it also
stems from pain
caused by what we're going to look at in
just a moment sliding or liguria so
that's one side of it but
it doesn't just include pain
aristotle also thinks
anger
characteristically
has a certain kind of pleasure
that follows or is accompanying it as
well hepa's thigh
is the word for for following and then
tina haydon haydon a is the opposite of
lupe it means pleasure or you know a
kind of enjoyment right delight you
could even translate it tina means a
certain it's qualifying it's not every
kind of pleasure and aristotle in fact
does tell us
that
it is pleasant to think that one will
obtain
what one aims at and you know what is it
that we're aiming at the hope of
something to come and so that's leading
us to the next
portion
this is absolutely central to anger
desire
desire for what
desire
for
apparent retaliation
timoras timorias phanomenes and
both of these terms can mean
multiple things and so we have to
hesitate or linger over this a bit
timorias comes from the word
for honor or social status teame
and timorias means in part
a restoration
of the status that has been damaged
injured lost reduced right setting
things right so retaliation
rectification would be another way of
translating it revenge is yet another
way
aristotle will also distinguish between
timorias
and
punishment
sometimes they overlap sometimes they're
they're the same thing right but the
idea here is that somebody does
something to you
you want to pay them back you want to
set things right you want you know
whatever it happens to be
so that's already a complex idea
phenomenase
this is the word that we get phenomenal
from or phenomena right
it means appearing or apparent
or it can even be translated as public
you know you want the person who
humiliated you you want them to
suffer and apologize and admit that they
were wrong in public in front of other
people right
so this open apparentness
being part of a sphere that doesn't just
include you is part of it but
you could also translate this as
imaginary
the
uh phenomenae
is within the realm of fantasia right
and so
you know this could be a retaliation
that only exists in your head this is
what happens often with passive
aggressive people when they
exhibit their anger towards others and
it's basically just their little drama
over here and nobody else notices it
right
so this is what the desire is for now
we've got a couple main components
desire apparent retaliation pain and
pleasure
what causes anger what provokes it what
gets it started here again
we're gonna see this word phenomenae
playing a major role right
there we go
so it is provoked by what aristotle
calls an
apparent sliding
so same thing with the apparent before
it could be imaginary it could be
something that is public it could be
something that's merely apparent of
course if it is something that appears
it could also be real it could be
something that does take place and is
noted as appearing precisely because
there's something substantive some
substantively there but the sliding
let's talk about that ologurian so this
is uh coming from the greek word for
less or few right we get uh oligarchy
from that rule by a few who tend to be
the rich right oligoria on sliding
you're reducing
somebody to
something that they don't want to have
going on and aristotle actually as we'll
talk about elsewhere
defines sliding and then characterizes
it in three different main modes and
then goes on to tell us quite a lot
about what counts as
sliding so let's just put that to the
side for a moment the sliding has a
couple important characteristics
that help to lead to the anger response
sliding isn't just against
anybody or anything in general
it's personal
it's connected with the person who gets
angry so the sliding is either against
self ace how tone right
that's the sort of reflexive
pronoun it's against me it's against you
it's against the other person who gets
angry i'm being slighted
or
it's against those one is concerned with
some translations will say things like
one's friends or one's family
but really the greek is
quite generic here anybody
who you
care about anybody literally who is of
you maybe you identify with them maybe
you think they're cool maybe you feel
bad for them and you try to take care of
them
maybe it's not even a person maybe it's
an inanimate object or a geographical
feature
or some sort of abstraction aristotle
will talk about people getting angry
when other people make fun of the things
that they
care about like philosophy
right so
you take the slight as being either
against you or against
anything anyone
that you care about you're walking down
the street and somebody says holy crap
is that an ugly dog that you're walking
it's your dog you could get angry at
them because they are insulting thereby
sliding your dog
that seems to be a real insult not just
a parent
the other
really central component
the sliding has to be
undeserved
or perceived at least as undeserved uh
to oligoren mei
prosecontos this pro secontos means
something like undeserved unbefitting
wrong and so if you think that somebody
is treating you
in the way that you deserve to be
treated then you're not going to get
angry it's only when the sliding is felt
to be
an injustice
an overlooking something that shouldn't
be
the case that one will actually become
angry so you notice just in this
definition aristotle is already
teaching us a lot about what anger
consists in what it involves what it
brings together in this complicated
package that we
use you know one word anger sometimes
others rage fury to denote and to
describe
anger is desire accompanied by pain also
accompanied by a certain pleasure for a
apparent retaliation
for an apparent sliding against oneself
or those one is concerned with the
sliding being
undeserved
there's at the entire
package for the aristotelian
conception of this emotion of anger
you